la mia idea è che fare cultura significa
veicolare una nuova idea di
intrattenimento che non si arrende agli
stereotipi della fruizione tradizionale
ma parliamo anche di numeri per avere un
quadro più chiaro nel messaggio che
voglio appunto veicolare adesso quindi
in italia vengono stampati circa 60 mila
titoli l'anno per una tiratura media di
circa 5.000 copie per titolo
questo significa che l'industria
editoriale italiana si posiziona al
settimo ottavo posto su scala mondiale e
al quarto quinto su scala europea
tuttavia l'italia è un paese in cui si
legge molto poco ciononostante questa
grandissima produzione l'italia continua
a essere un paese in cui si legge poco
su 60 milioni di abitanti considerando
gli individui che hanno più di sei anni
ci rendiamo conto che circa 30 milioni
di persone non leggono 25 milioni di
persone leggono un libro l'anno e
soltanto quattro milioni di persone
leggono almeno un libro al mese che
consentitemi secondo me è il minimo
sindacale e che da soli quindi
assicurano più della metà delle vendite
e garantiscono la sopravvivenza di un
settore che fattura 3 miliardi e mezzo
di euro l'anno stampa 60 mila titoli e
impiega 40 mila persone
quindi i sono in molti naturalmente a
chiedersi come si possa fare per
cambiare radicalmente questa situazione
per voltare pagina ogni anno numerose
iniziative per promuovere il libro e la
lettura vengono promosse da enti
pubblici come le istituzioni le
biblioteche le scuole ma anche da
numerosi soggetti privati come le
librerie come le associazioni ma queste
azioni servono davvero a incentivare
l'amore per la lettura perché un conto è
vendere più libri ma un conto è
stimolare davvero l'abitudine verso la
lettura e quindi passare dall eccezione
alla regola
da una lettura sporadica a far sì che la
lettura sia un'abitudine degli individui
alla in questo senso molte iniziative
appunto sono state fatte ma l'idea è che
bisogna passare attraverso la
spettacolarizzazione della cultura cioè
dalla cultura deve fare e saper fare
intrattenimento vero e spettacolo quindi
partire dal libro e del libro creare
intrattenimento
in questo senso alcuni un esempio
virtuoso è quello dei festival letterari
in italia i festival letterari l'italia
hanno uno straordinario successo
uno dei primi e il festival letterature
di mantova che è nato nel 1997 e da quel
momento ne sono nati tantissimi in ogni
parte d'italia con tematiche
completamente diverse e tutti pur
essendo diciamo ematiche che non
dovrebbero attrarre un turismo di massa
hanno registrato invece vette
inaspettate di partecipazione
quindi abbiamo assistito a folle che non
disposte anche a pagare perché molti di
questi eventi ricordiamolo sono a
pagamento per assistere a tavole rotonde
sulla matematica sulla scienza sulla
fisica sulla filosofia affollando quindi
le piazze e gli stand della città che
ospitano il festival e contribuendo così
a creare un indotto culturale ed
economica attorno a quello che è un vero
e proprio sistema infatti l'italia
dovete sapere che ha il primato europeo
circa il numero dei festival ci siamo il
paese in europa che ha il maggior numero
di festival e oltre mantova naturalmente
che è il più famoso e oltre il salone
del libro di torino che però un esempio
a parte perché in realtà sono del libro
di torino che nasce nell 88 e che
sicuramente nel settore l'evento più
importante perché a caratura
internazionale perché a 1.400 espositori
perché a 2000 e relatori in tre giorni
rimane però un evento a parte perché
prevede anche appunto l'esposizione
delle case editrici è un po come la
nostra francoforte ma parlando tornando
ai festival ce ne sono anche di
dimensioni diverse come il festival
dell'economia della filosofia di modena
ma addirittura realtà molto piccole come
il festival di gavoi o di sarzana
pensate che il festival di gavoi nella
barbagia sarda dove non c'è
assolutamente nulla riesce ad attrarre
per tre giorni a luglio di ogni anno
miglia ahi ahi migliaia di persone hanno
dovuto costruire delle strutture
alberghiere e queste persone vanno ad
ascoltare degli scrittori quindi vi
direte sì ma allora siamo sulla buona
strada sì ma la domanda rimane sempre
quella cioè i festival letterari anche
se hanno una partecipazione così vasta
riescono a stimolare non solo l'acquisto
di libri ma anche la lettura come
attività quotidiana
a mio parere non sempre la mia idea
appunto è che saper intrattenere quello
che ho detto all'inizio
significa non è una diminuzione spetta
al fare cultura
ma significa declinare il libro insieme
a tante altre arti e fare a partire da
questo un vero intrattenimento questa
sfida che ho lanciato sul fare cultura
sul fare cultura comunicando appunto con
comunicando un codice che sia anche il
codice che parlano le nuove generazioni
e quindi che possa attrarre un pubblico
giovane che il pubblico del lettore che
io chiamo di mezzo cioè si situa tra i
lettori forti e i lettori che non
leggono e su quel target soprattutto e
le persone scusate che non leggono e su
quel target perché dobbiamo diciamo
focalizzarci e quindi ho lanciato questa
sfida a me stessa e al territorio in cui
ero decisa avevo deciso di ritornare
dopo una vita appunto trascorso
all'estero e parlo di taormina e decido
quattro anni fa di creare il festival
internazionale del libro le belle
lettere taobuk e l'ho deciso di farlo
proprio a taormina perché la città che
mi ricollegava alle mie origini e questo
festival non poteva che nascere a
taormina fondata a 2400 anni fa sul
monte tauro dagli esuli della colonia
della prima colonia greca in sicilia
l'ha distrutta naxos nella baia
sottostante e taormina ecco è stata
costruita cementata dal sogno di
costruire una città che fosse rivolta
verso la loro terra d'origine per non
recidere mai appunto il legame con le
loro con la loro storia più recente e le
belle lettere che noi abbiamo voluto che
io ho voluto che fossero appunto le
protagoniste di un festival che pur si
apre a tutte le arti hanno continuato a
essere
amate dai tanti viaggiatori scrittori
che nei secoli successivi hanno scelto
taormina come meta del loro viaggio di
formazione
quindi nasce il festival internazionale
del libro è questo ad esempio il teatro
antico perché l'idea appunto che bisogna
per attrarre un numero sempre crescente
di persone ma anche farle leggere di più
perché questo è lo scopo fare
intrattenimento a partire dal libro
incrociando il libro con altre arti e
soprattutto rendendo la città che ospita
il festival un vero e proprio villaggio
della letteratura in cui tutti gli
attori del territorio
imprenditori albergatori in quei sette
giorni del festival devono vivere e
allestire la città come un enorme libro
quindi i luoghi che tradizionalmente
sono adibiti all intrattenimento come il
teatro antico di taormina devono tornare
a essere agorà intesa come luogo in cui
si scambiano le idee questo ad esempio
il teatro antico qui abbiamo realizzato
un dibattito politico c'era all'epoca
veltroni la danza la danza è un altro
grandissimo
appunto attore del festival ciao buche
delle lettere perché attraverso la danza
siamo riusciti a pure ad attrarre quel
pubblico che magari non sarebbe mai
avvenuto al festival due attori due
attori che interpretano in maniera
magistrale il testo e quindi fanno
vivere il testo nello specifico le
conoscete tutti sono vincenzo pirrotta
che la terra anzi due grandissimi nomi
del teatro
eravamo al teatro antico piero pelù che
c'entra piano per un front man delitti
va perché lui ha scritto un libro ha
scritto un libro è comunque il
denominatore
di tutti gli incontri del festival è il
libro perché il libro è il protagonista
incrocia nel paradigma le altre arti ma
rimane il protagonista assoluto della
rassegna perché il protagonista assoluto
dell'idea quindi in questo caso abbiamo
presentato il libro e poi una
performance live
sullo stesso palco c'era però anche
francesco p eccolo che ha vinto il
premio strega entrambi hanno parlato
della loro biografia che incrocia le due
storie la storia con la s minuscola che
la storia di piero pelù è la storia
della con la s maiuscola perché piccola
ha raccontato gli ultimi 40 anni della
vita politica italiana
con questo libro appunto che ha vinto il
premio strega la piazza ix aprile perché
la piazza ix aprile questa slide per me
è importantissima perché il cuore e 11
appunto dei fulcri della mia idea cioè
il fatto che la città deve tornare ad
aprire i propri luoghi come appunto la
piazza l'agorà agli incontri culturali
quindi abbiamo deciso di scendere tra
virgolette in piazza e aprirla al
dibattito sui libri un momento molto
emozionante perché tutto parte dalle
emozioni se riusciamo dal libro a
emozionare riusciamo anche ad abituare
il pubblico alla lettura
l'abbraccio tra il premio oscar nicola
piovani e lo scrittore cileno luis
sepulveda che abbiamo premiato e abbiamo
ospitato all'interno della stessa serata
è stato veramente un'emozione molto
forte perché proponiamo
personaggi di caratura internazionale
e anche sempre seguendo il paradigma
dell'incrocio tra le arti il premio
oscar ha suonato naturalmente oltre a
presentare il suo libro
lectio magistralis si parla anche di
legalità si parla di legalità perché
anche questo è uno dei temi portanti dei
nostri incontri questo caso abbiamo la
seconda carica dello stato
nella stessa serata nello stesso
contesto in cui proponiamo l'emozione di
sepulveda l'emozione della musica anche
un'alexia un altro momento del dei
nostri incontri che illustra il format
anche il format è molto importante
perché noi proponiamo un format con
incontri molto brevi come se fossimo in
televisione tra l'altro in televisione a
mio parere si fa poca cultura legata al
mondo dei libri se ci fate i programmi
che parlano dei libri o non esistono
sono in fasce orarie assurde come di
notte o in veramente momenti poco
fruibili e sono davvero pochi programmi
che parlano di libri un altro momento la
musica l'arte l'arte quindi l'altra e
l'arte è un altro elemento molto
importante per voi veicolare emozioni e
legarle libri quindi abbiamo deciso
deciso di ospitare una mostra
fotografica
del mio uno dei fotografi preferiti e
ferdinando scianna allievo di cartier
bresson
gli ho chiesto di realizzare questa
mostra per noi lui ha accettato è stato
molto felice è venuta inaugurarla ma
naturalmente presente il libro perché
ricordiamo deve esserci sempre
il libro l'arte povera
questo è un questa è una slide
bellissima molto colorata che ci
racconta un altro aspetto del festival
che quello legata appunto all'idea che
tutta la città deve essere un grande
villaggio della letteratura anche negli
arredi urbani quindi abbiamo chiesto
all'artista catanese cartura che
realizza appunto delle installazioni in
cartapesta legate al mondo del libro di
arredare taormina con delle creazioni
che rimandassero completamente al libro
la musica e la musica è molto importante
l'abbiamo vista prima con l'esibizione
del premio oscar ma anche una musica che
sia più vivace e quindi in questo caso
gli ulivisti in jeans che tra un
incontro e l'altro hanno appunto ci
hanno coinvolti con le loro note
effervescenti sempre arte perché l'arte
pittorica in questo caso
da declinare con le belle lettere
l'avete riconosciuto tutti e il
giornalista beppe severgnini che è
venuto ad inaugurare la mostra
naturalmente parlando del suo libro
anche la scienza anche la scienza un
ruolo importante perché un'altra forma
di dialogo e di comunicazione questo era
l'incontro con piero angela
ci sono state qui a quest'incontro
duemila persone perché appunto molto
mediatico il decano della divulgazione
scientifica in italia anche cibo una
forma d'arte
questo caso parliamo di streetfood
streetfood all'italiana quindi abbiamo
deciso di integrare
questo aspetto che mancavano edizioni
precedenti è stato un grandissimo
successo che la buona tavola
l'apprezzano tutti
infine gli imprenditori gli imprenditori
sono importanti perché sono degli attori
fondamentali nel tessuto urbano ii o
coinvolti chiedendogli di declinare il
concetto di arte quindi di design e
adottando nella propria vetrina un
autore ospite del festival quindi
esponendo il suo libro è un oggetto di
design legato al mondo della lettura
infine ho pensato che in qualche modo
dovevo collegare il festival oggi
moderno contemporaneo a quelle che sono
appunto quella che è stata la taormina
del passato da sempre crocevia di storie
narrazioni come faccio come faccio ho
pensato ma qui è passato il mondo le
grandi muse della storia si sono fermate
a taormina tra da truman capote a
tenersi williams abbia avuto personaggi
incredibili
non c'è traccia di questi personaggi
allora mi sono inventata 21 luoghi si
sono inventati dal punto di vista degli
allestimenti ma questi luoghi esistono
davvero
mi sono inventato un percorso che si
chiama taormina cult e che prevede 21
luoghi in cui le grandi muse della
storia si sono fermate abbiamo quindi
contraddistinto questi luoghi con dei
pannelli in ferro battuto con la
descrizione della tappa in quattro
lingue attraverso il qr code per
stimolare anche un turismo
come dire anche individuale basta avere
uno smartphone e ci si ritrova davanti a
tutto il percorso e quindi questo sempre
al fine di stimolare la lettura perché
ognuna di queste tappe è legata poi a un
libro suggerito qual è il collante la
teca s abbiamo deciso di collegare le 21
tappe con quest'app è molto vintage allo
scopo appunto di permettere anche agli
ospiti del festival o al pubblico del
festival di compiere il percorso in
maniera anche originale
nell'asta nella foto sono giancarlo de
cataldo lo scrittore de cataldo che era
ospite del festival e nicola piovani che
hanno fatto insieme il giro e questo ha
dato un po anche di brio a quello che un
percorso dedicato ovviamente delle
figure del passato e questa è la mia
idea per passare da una diciamo lettura
eccezionale alla regola della lettura
grazie